панель штайнмаєр
ви побували урою не щури районі
конфлікту в сусідній Україні рахунок провал
він його сусу швидко напиши вражині прямо у
нас skull вася ворожі шукаю людою чекають
рахунок ми проїхали ми часто про вмову гуму
ситуації в окупованих сепаратистам
регіонах алли не маємо чіткого у яблунь
ще й менше big так званої
демаркаційної лінії життя душ
змінилося а
яншина словами витрачу неробочими вся
економіка у той же навпаки та producing жити
ті важливі артерії тут у середніх українах
народження там вгадають добро і ще ми
тут побував і
за крима тому ж ми дали людям хочеш
страх і знайди на 1000 ситуація на зло
хитається тупикові на зараження
початківець за передачі в частині цієї
режим припаяні його в кількох ви мені
ще його буде до 3 ось цього конфлікти 2
зали знаємо її з такими конфліктами і
ми знаємо про натиснули нил і йшов повз
епістаз для оптимізму
про те наше завдання знову і знову шукає
ти можеш вивести скоро сором і на
пружині
ви карстового ти розділення у вогню як на
році здобутий себе подалі хп аромовані
ми не можемо of досить тис режимом
пунктуації у вогню на витік seven
протираєте сидимо на ми dc протягну перед
варіть режим тисячі напасти, але ж суть
з боїв
а потім знову видно ось абрамова на ще
до політичного вирішення оскільки c
ложку здогадуються всі овець та єдиний
ногах botas пробний політичний ви
вирішення всього конфлікту закінчилося
нічим пробуксовувати чесну запасну
план на ви paddock ще й усього разу
нічого не вийдуть
гадаю на мені можна схоже ось assist in
show сіна махання без перспективніше
нібито cygnus або доповіддю і в ключ на з
мінськими домовленостями
досвіду на деяких ми напали ра йому хто
нібито знав мету конфлікт розгорнувся про
нам не було на bespeco seven силоміць
вийде спити контролю диван і стала села
на явно ситуація досить складна і
змінить її наші спини завдання для чого
ми бачимо а переговори з росією про
розбавляємо з України я рада ще пройти
мами моєму францію як сильного партнера
і ми продовжимо а проти ти на цінні
лише цьому рахунок створення за зовнішньою
політики а там ще ми зубів я за не
придумає я титул громадян bodies of
tanks
aleksand